cinéma avec la sortie cette semaine du
film américain hors d'atteinte avec
George Clun le médecin deurgence la
rencontre entre le réalisateur de sexe
mensonge et vidéo et l'acteur américain
a été fructueuse Nicole cornuanglois et
Frédéric
dearue en toutes circonstances George
Cloun semble toujours le type sympa le
copain que l'on aimerait avoir même s'il
n'y a pas
d'urgence il est prêt à rire de tout sur
un
tournage alors forcément lorsqu'il
braque une banque il le fait avec charme
et l'employé ne peut
résister pas les billets qui sont en
dessous s'il vous plaît
d'accord c'est la première fois que vous
faites braquer oui vous vous débrouillez
très bien faites-moi sourire sinon on va
croire que c'est un
hold la désinvolture de ce gentleman
cambrioleur Estelle
votre
personnalité je suis un voleur j' les B
le réptez pas c'est juste entre vous et
moi pasy d'être sérieux le personnage de
Jacques F à peine évadé de prison après
ce Brage raté tombe sur une femme
détective qui va bouleverser sa vie à
tout point de
vuen
typ vie pour l'amour d'une
femme c'est un romantique mais son
histoire est vraiment
intéressante se réveille au bout de 40
ans il regarde enfin autour de lui et
décide de mieux
faire la seule chose certaine c'est
qu'il ne veut pas retourner en prison
AER cette femme devient donc une
question de vie ou de
mort c'estuttre le meilleur rôle pour
George Clounet est-il sensible aux
critiques quand on est jeune tout est
haut ou bas on même on me haie quand on
est plus âgé on arrive à une sorte de
sérénité qui est sur une ligne médiane
et vous essayer de la conserver quoi
qu'il arrive entre fantasme rêve ou
réalité retour en arrière et projection
sur l'avenir c'est une histoire main et
subtile et l'on ressent une certaine
jubilation devant temps de séduction si
on s'en allait oui
à shanghï le talent